yeah I had a teacher  Professor Dr Whitney Combs doctor Dr  Whitney Combs and I remember the first  time I took basic techniques of acting  my freshman year okay still talking like  him and I'm sitting there in a classroom  and he gets up and goes  um if you're here for uh just an easy  elective  please raise your hand don't be afraid  please raise your hand if you're just  here at for a free it's an easy elective  just raise your hand and I I was always  a goofy kid I was about I was like  seconds away from lifting my hand up and  I didn't and then about seven or eight  people raised their hands like yeah  they're like no if you quickly leave my  classroom they're like what no seriously  get out of my classroom and he kicked  those people who just wanted an easy egg